good morning Hank it's Tuesday I
recently learned it's been 510 days
since my fifth novel Turtles all the way
down was published and if I'd written
just like a paragraph or two each of
those 510 days I would have at least
finished a draft of a sixth novel but I
haven't and today I want to talk about
why this came to my attention by the way
because the paperback edition of turtles
all the way down is being published
today in the United States it's like the
hardcover except less expensive and also
the cover is softer and there's a Q&A at
the back and we fixed a couple typos but
yeah I haven't written a novel in the
last 500 ten days partly because I've
been working on other stuff crash course
European history our project with
partners and a health TV and movie
adaptations but then again I've had some
kind of day job for most of my writing
life the truth he's a little more
complicated Turtles all the way down has
been very generously received both by
critics and by readers and I want to
emphasize how grateful I am to have a
large audience and even to have my books
reviewed in places like the New York
Times and The Guardian let alone
positively but the process of publishing
the book was very difficult for me I
realized this is the pinnacle of
champagne problems but I was really
overwhelmed with fear about whether
people would like it and whether it was
a good and useful thing to put into the
world and whether it was the best book
it could be and so on also and this is
the champagne yes problem of them all
when you have a lot of success it can
start to feel like everyone has to
develop an opinion of your work even if
they aren't particularly familiar with
it or particularly interested in it like
I haven't seen Fifty Shades of Grey but
I still feel like I have to have an
opinion about Fifty Shades of Grey
and I kind of do have an opinion
although maybe the opinion is wrong
maybe the movies amazing but when that
happens when you make a thing that
people like or in some cases dislike so
much they define themselves in
opposition to it it can be pretty
destabilizing writing stories has always
been like a way out of myself trying to
inhabit other people's consciousnesses
can give me a break from having to
inhabit my own but publishing those
stories is about something else a
complicated mess of wanting people to
like me wanting to be successful hoping
that my stories might be useful or
important to the people who read them
and wanting to pass on some of the gifts
that other people's stories have given
me and so for at least the past like
decade writing for me hasn't only or
even primarily
about writing it's also about touring
and publicity and movie rights all of
which I am ridiculously lucky to stress
about but which I nonetheless find
stressful and all of that together means
that for the moment anyway I'm not
really able to write much fiction but I
haven't stopped writing instead I
started writing in a place that felt
quieter and safer to me where people who
liked my work could find it but people
who didn't care too probably wouldn't I
started a podcast with a somewhat weird
premise reviewing facets of the human
centered planet on a five-star scale and
gave it a hard to spell named the
Anthropocene reviewed and for the last
year and a half I've been writing about
everything from scratch and sniff
stickers and the Taco Bell breakfast
menu to the practice of googling
strangers and it has been so fun and so
fulfilling to explore a new kind of
writing and to seek out places where my
personal experiences connect to
Universal ones like I was way too into
scratch and sniff stickers when I was a
kid an early symptom of my long-term
fascination with virtualised experience
but I didn't understand the strange and
beautiful chemistry of those stickers
until I started writing about them the
pleasures of unexpected discovery turn
out to be similar whether you're writing
fiction or nonfiction I do intend to
publish more novels many more hopefully
but in the meantime I'm very grateful
that the ones I've written are still
finding new readers books are quiet and
interior experiences in a very loud
world and so are my favorite podcasts so
regardless of the medium I just want to
say thank you for listening Hank I'll
see you on Friday